the Han Solo Olivia is changing
directors so now what happens
what exactly is Doctor Strange doing in
the latest set photo from infinity war
and it's transformers the last night
worth seeing all that more coming up on
ET at the movies hey everybody I'm ash
Carlton I am John Boone there is so much
to talk about today but I just want to
get straight to news of the week because
as soon as this story broke I knew
you're going to need to talk about it
can I just tell you that I was on a
flight back to LA when this news broke
quite shocking news coming out of the
Star Wars universe director still Lord
and Chris Miller famous for Jump Street
movies on the lego movie were fired from
the untitled Han Solo movie in the midst
of filming if this isn't
I'm so confused it hasn't like it's not
done filming it hasn't not so they're in
the middle of film they're in the middle
of filming they're almost done and
people are comparing it to the Edgar
Wright Peyton Reed ant-man Fiasco but
it's like no they weren't even thinking
about roaming yet this is kind of this
is kind of augurs Lucasfilm president
Kathleen Kennedy and Phil Lord and Chris
Miller released a statement both saying
the cliche creative differences it
sounds like that's really true but
surprisingly they're they said they're
keeping that may 2018 release date so
maybe not as extensive reshoots and
rewrites as we thought but then it seems
so weird if it's good enough so far to
get to this point let them just finish
the movie
or they should have fired on months ago
how do you just fire them in the middle
I don't understand you if you're hiring
Phil Lord and Chris Miller you know
you're getting this kind of Lord Miller
movie so wrong so who do you want to
take over this bad boy so the one of the
frontrunners have been circulating
around the internet is that Ron Howard
might take over which is intriguing and
then a lot of things a lot of the
internet is saying hey we want Edgar
right I think he's a little busy it's
like the middle of baby driver promotion
and then they would have to go he would
have to go straight to set but I would
like that good luck to whichever
director picks this up mid with like REO
lo eggs left
good luck to you but what else is
talking about this what else oh god from
space two superheroes
we still have three Marvel movies until
infinity wars we have spider-man
homecoming Thor Ragnarok in black
panther but they are on the set right
now and this week Robert Downey jr.
posted a picture with Benedict
Cumberbatch Benedict long and the Mark
Ruffalo and then the fiction I love it
is better to come about to drinking hot
sauce because it's so respected I think
when I first saw it I was just so happy
they're all drinking Lacroix they are
packing a lot of people into that movie
and I'm really here for and so this
wasn't exactly news we knew all these
people were going to be in the movie but
hey I'm so excited that and like I guess
it is news look at us look at dr.
strange outfit I was gonna say look at
the costumes I mean that's something new
at we what they mean who knows uh did
you rent your six piece yet comin comin
well should we move on to even more
superheroes ret explode those stories
you see exclusive of the week it's the
20th anniversary of Batman and Robin we
have much more of this on et online.com
but Jenny direct oh caught up with
Alicia Silverstone Alicia Silverstone
release yeah she wants to perform a
fancy I made it fancy and guess what she
would like to play bad girl again take a
look I think if I did it right now I'd
be much better bad girl you know the
time we hit it let's look at you in my
dream about an actor then I just like
didn't want to be in the suit it was all
comfortable I think we just figured out
your toys and quickly I think Maggie is
a little smaller very massive is in the
suit yeah it's just like well you know
George George has the best you know all
I think of it stuff maybe tone down the
babes with nipples and and and I get I
do much better job there is gonna be a
back role movie we know Joss Whedon is
doing one for DC so who knows I would
you want to see you do it again I got
great yeah get the whole cast back you
don't get them all back yet chrismedonne
when I was Batman - sag bring back to
that I love all chief about you issues
like I'd like to do it again but maybe
just like less yeah that's going on in
the costumes well let's move on this
week more heroes have a lot of heroes
going on yeah
well sure superheroes Autobots Autobots
Transformers last night starring Mark
Wahlberg and Josh Duhamel and a newcomer
named Isabel motor but et was onset of
this movie which was as Michael Bay as
you can possibly go because they
recreated Stonehenge and then would you
guess what he done blown it up Cameron
Mathison was on set take a look but to
face this action and things go booth the
explosions are primed and they are ready
and so are we
for our transformers the last night
exclusive oh man here we go the nice
thing about the last night is you really
don't need to know anything about any
other Transformers movie to come into it
my head hurts
yeah I mean really if you missed
age of extinction which I think a lot of
people kind of did I think a lot of
people were like complete their
dinosaurs in these now yeah there's got
to learn of these now but they just
explain the plot of that movie and
voiceover but you pass not them what do
we think well how are we feeling
Hey look if you like things slowing up
you like Michael Bay you're going to
enjoy them you can enjoy yourself you
know what he said I don't make smoothies
for critics but it's not there's there's
so much going on my brain feels like
scrambled eggs trying to decipher this
movie I will say I my problem with it
while I do problems I have one problem
that I wrote about in my review on easy
online your redeeming love your review
made me laugh a lot um but my other
problem is this movie is true and a half
hours long even if you like transformers
movies there's no reason you need that
much of it from now on if a studio head
or whoever if Optimus Prime himself gets
a script and it's a hundred and twenty
pages I want someone to rip the middle
like 40 out toss it put it film it I'm
sure it would still be fine know we
always say this every movie should be
two hours or less - especially a
Transformers movie should not be more
than two hours
there it is it's a lot of confusion and
by a lot
she means runtime reviews runtime so
where does last night place in your
transformers ranking out of all of them
and more importantly who should replace
Florida Miller our Han Solo you wit let
us know in the comments below like
subscribe come back next week where
we're talking about baby driver that's
right yeah
[Music]